talking about this video playing with
Vidal we download which baby I can play
some other opening for a change let's
play a bank or gambit what you do
against this I think they had they do
this one of many possible continuations
oh wow that looks dangerous it
definitely is dangerous you know
I looked at something like that as a
weapon against the bloomenfeld and
recommended that to a student it's it is
very dangerous
white has got very nice compensation for
the pawn show evidence is just sighs
water
okay so it's not easy to develop if I
play here there's always these six kind
of things but probably I have to do it I
mean a d5 pawn is a absolute annoyance
okay now he's shooting for for the
purpose to these six if I take the five
there is Bishop d6
it looks like an interesting move at
least Wow okay so the question is still
if I kick here and let's do this first
it takes with the bishop I mean if I
just take twice on d5 am I losing 95
Bishop takes Bishop jinx
does he have is that winning or
something I don't don't see it I don't
see it
Bishop takes Bishop James screen shakes
okay so he's attacking b7 I can't play
Queen b6 though I'm
well black is up to center porn so if
I'm not getting killed immediately I'm
winning okay I can trade Queens now if I
like one walk castle don't see what's
wrong with castling
now whites attack pretty much has
evaporated into not much night before
and then d5 looks very tempting and
let's do it
I can also take f3 hmm well okay what
kind of move was that white resigns
what's there such an obvious issue on d5
or I thought he played a play d5 yeah
now anyway
both came into consideration I wanted to
take and then play d5 hard to say it's
probably both good and this is kind of
gambit is quite dangerous so I'm pretty
I'm pretty unsure here it and the engine
just says this doesn't work at all so
probably white has to play something
different to Bishop f4 Knight c3 is what
the what the engine gives it is very
difficult to play this kind of position
if you look at this here for example if
I take and Bishop takes the black
doesn't have a good move here after
Knight c3 I probably have to maybe just
cancel and cause this isn't that
convincing now it's quite interesting
either this doesn't work I could have
chicken on f4 so that the Queen b6
looked quite convincing until you made
that pre move arrow but I think this is
more or less winning if you look at this
back I mean I'm to sent the pawns up
plus ninety four coming Bishop f6 coming
it's too much okay well thanks for
watching